[Music]
so thank you guys for stepping out and
coming out to our little talk here this
is our talk is on dynamic compute
options we'll introduce ourselves here
in a moment so my name is my Kinser on
the vp of delivery for dev 9 I have been
in the industry for about 24 years I
very early a doctor of Google I asked
was on the original beta program for a
Google App Engine so that's just kind of
some of my background I also was a
certified architect with Google I was
number 170 so my little joke is we've
got about 25 so certified engineers and
there's about 2,000 certified so we have
1% of the world's population of the
certified engineers so anyway I want to
introduce Michael Michaels with me
starting off the conversation here so he
was good morning everyone
is that my name's Michael got her a gym
with the Fred Hutchinson Cancer Research
Center I've been there about 15 years
now running HPC at various levels
introducing the Fred Hutchinson our
mission is the elimination of cancer and
related diseases as a cause of human
suffering and death what's not on the
slide is that about 2015 our president
gave us 10 years to reach this goal so
that's an ambitious goal but we have 300
over 300 faculty and over 3,000
employees that are all focused on
reaching this goal so I feel pretty
confident that we're gonna get there our
research has expanded beyond just cancer
we're starting to find links to viruses
the world's microbiome in the
development and progression of cancer
ously research area expands with every
passing day I'm part of the scientific
computing team we're a small team of
about seven folks we're responsible for
supporting our researchers and their
compute needs we support almost a full
stack compute hardware the software the
tools as well as some high-performance
storage
so we have a smallish cluster about 1200
cores over 510 systems right now we're
running about 1.2 petabytes of data that
grows by 24 terabytes every day we have
some miscellaneous systems large large
compute nodes that we use for casual
prototyping work and some other
miscellaneous functions that aren't
satisfied by the cluster but it's a
pretty diverse environment and it's a
growing environment so the core of our
talk is high performance computing what
is high performance computing well at
the hutch high performs convening is
pretty much computational resource beot
beyond what's available under your desk
we scale horizontally meaning we use
commodity Hardware we just add more
Hardware as we need more capacity it's
what you might call a Beowulf or a
shared nothing style cluster versus
something like a Blue Gene a Cray or one
of those more exotic machines why do we
need it well we've got about 7 years
left to cure this cancer problem so we
need a lot of compute we're answering
it's asking a lot of questions that
require a significant amount of compute
capacity so how do we use HPC up the
hutch we have I've just picked out three
free research projects here give you a
quick introduction to what sort of work
they're doing the OP tides project is a
collaboration that identifies new drugs
and therapies for very treatment
resistant tumors of a head neck throat
and of the brain as well one of their
key problems is how you get drugs across
the blood-brain membrane to deal with
brain cancers and other other diseases
they're a very diverse project they work
a lot of proteomics data they use a lot
of kinetics data type fruit
high-throughput sequencing base calls
and alignments as well as protein
structure and functional predictions
just giving the idea of the scale their
work they've used 141,000 CPU hours
since the first of May the Mallik lab is
a run by dr. Harman Mallik he's part of
our basic sciences division it's I've
read through his research his area of
research twice and I still don't
entirely understand it it's uh he's
basically looking at the problems that
can be classified under kinetics of
evolutionary conflict does a lot of de
novo genome assembly so new genomes come
in to try to put them together figure
out what's interesting about that how
they've changed short read mapping
single nucleotide polymorphism discovery
they're probably on a smaller scale of
compute for the center at about eleven
thousand CPU hours since the first of
may and finally the gecko project this
is a really large projects been ongoing
for a number of years at the center
we've got about forty thousand
participants in this one and this one is
basically aimed at colorectal cancers
and how the environment affects your
risk for receipt for getting a
colorectal cancer they do a lot of work
with whole genome so they do a lot of
work looking for new genotypes and the
existing datasets G by E which is
genetic versus the environment how the
environment affects your genome and then
how that transfers into your risk of
getting a cancer they have they're like
I said they're one of the larger
projects they've used about two hundred
five thousand core hours since the first
of May so with an institution this large
we have a very diverse toolset we have a
few of the big ones our bio conductor is
our you know our meat and bread in the
first-class tools that we maintain we're
getting more interest in machine
learning these days as we move into more
clinical data and then we've got the old
workhorses Sam tools the car things like
that do your your traditional genetic
analysis we've also got a lot of custom
pipelines that are being built at the
center where people are trying to came
together different tools using a variety
of systems scripts more modern things
air flow et cetera
to came together but various
to answer their problems we maintain all
these using a couple of things easy
building l mod that lets us sort of
build our our tools in a reproducible
manner as well as deliver them easily to
our researchers so discuss the cluster
at the beginning of the presentation
we're a big slurm shop we've been using
it since the early to dot days it's an
open source project that began with the
Lawrence Livermore labs it's a very high
performance solution that's used on well
as you can see there are six of the top
set ten supercomputers the emphasis on
performance is well it's a key part of
how they developed and how it's been
very useful for us the big system tuning
guide indicates that they had almost two
million tasks on 122,000 compute nodes
and they started those in three hundred
and twenty-two seconds which is fairly
impressive a little bit more down to
earth three thirty thousand tasks on
15,000 Linux nodes and that took 30
seconds so we're looking at a very high
performance solution for managing and
distributing workload to a cluster
unfortunately this comes with some costs
to get this kind of performance all the
nodes in the cluster must share the same
configuration they all have to know
about each other you can't have nodes
just joining randomly throughout the day
so you have to the cluster has to have
consistent view of what the rest of it
the cluster looks like so we add or
remove nodes this is a disruptive task
where you have to sort of reconfigure
the cluster and tell everybody but
there's a new configuration we decided
we really needed to keep with slurm like
I said it's a key strategies key
strategic component of our environment
we don't want our researchers to have to
learn a new submit job submission system
and we wanted them to be able to just
use their existing scripts run with the
same command same options things like
that whether they were running on
premises or into the cloud they probably
make a real quick note there slurm
the partner said that the company that
builds and develops slurm actually did a
partnership with Google and did a kind
of an alpha release of a dynamic
basically build up a cluster do your
work and tear it down that still hasn't
really been released yet so well we'll
cover that and a little bit may get into
more the technical side of it but is it
important to kind of note that the
challenges we had really over the fact
that the configuration has to be known
ahead of time of once you build your
infrastructure so the cluster can
communicate there's no cluster
communication amongst new nodes right
yeah this is there are a number of ways
of doing this
and since our approach we didn't want to
kink anything for our community we had
to tie into a lot of resources that are
back on campus so that's a big a big
what do you wanna call it a big boat
anchor on using the cloud is that we
have to tie into a lot of on campus
resources I don't know how many of you
have worked with or familiar with slurm
it's pretty straightforward you've got a
controller in the middle you've got your
damage that run on the individual nodes
that accept work from the from the
controller and then you have a database
daemon that setre sits in the background
and does all the accounting work and
keeps records about what jobs were
running and what jobs are running
there's a few different commands for
interfacing with the cluster they're
sort of listed up there as Ron dispatch
we're one of the ones that just allow
you to dispatch jobs to cluster or
cancel them or see how they're
progressing through the through the
rivet session there's two options
there's a batch option and an
interactive option we do have a lot of
users that use a lot of course
interactively where they will fire up a
job and just from a shell fire off
various art tasks or things like that so
it's a very very diverse workflow
throughout the center data management
here where's the data well it's all on
campus so right now we come back to the
campus from our various cloud clusters
to read and write data that's a bit of a
another anchor and I'm never constraint
on our design as well as the fact that
we're still using LDAP and the Kerberos
authentication back to you on campus
host so that's the problem we have a
tightly coupled infrastructure dependent
computing environment and we want to
take that and replicate it in the cloud
so ongoing cloud is going to be a big
part of our computing strategy and we
are adopting sort of a cloud first
approach to computing gives us a lot of
options allows us to you scale capacity
on demand and then scale it back as
circumstances warrant we also get new
options and new technologies easily and
quickly rather than having to wait to
provision things on campus we've um
we've deployed into another cloud
provider I'll leave it to you to guess
which one and that's been moderately
successful given the constraints of
having to use on campus resources for
data access but for some work we're
doing a lot of stimulation it's been
highly successful in being able to give
people the capacity they need to
accomplish their goals so what we wanted
to do next was expand into GCP there's a
lot of exciting things going on there
there's some new capabilities of
different ways of managing resources so
it's fairly exciting to to approach
Google and see see what we can gain from
there there's chance for us to really
diversify our compute our infrastructure
as well as sort of mitigate any of the
risks that might come along with adding
a single vendor solution for our cloud
computing salute
computing but how do we solve this
problem we didn't really have any
experience with TCP we'd been working
with Amazon for quite some time so we
want to make this happen quickly we want
to use best practices we don't have a
solid deployment but we don't really
know what they are for Google so this is
where we look to bring in a partner that
have the experience with Google to help
us get the solution we have Deb Nye at
Google subject matter expert experience
with GCP with biology healthcare and as
well as being northwest neighbors so at
this point I'll turned over the audio to
you my cancer alright so uh so as
Michael had mentioned we were a partner
here with Google and nice thing is I get
to mention this when I every time I go
to downtown Seattle I Drive by their
campus they have a big sign it's a it's
a cool campus so so it's nice that they
were kind of in our back yard we do have
our company does have some health care
and research background as well as and
through some of the solutions that we've
built so I'll just go this real fast who
are we we're Dabney and we are a custom
software development company based out
of the Pacific Northwest we kind of
introduced ourselves into the cloud
world about six or so years ago at that
time we realized cloud was not a trend
and we still stand by that you think
it's gonna stick around for a while so
that kind of got us into the games are
working with Google about two years ago
and became a premier partner we've got
you know 25 some certified engineers so
when when coming here to get introduced
to Fred hutch it was actually a really
really awesome time to build a share how
we build infrastructure and how we build
outer solutions and we do a slightly
different at least we think we do and
we'll talk about kind of what that
solution is here so kind of recap some
of what what it is we were trying to
accomplish it like with a problem that's
all we're trying to solve we had some
kind of unique good strengths we you
know they have 400 some you know
projects going on you know thousands of
researchers around the world who are
actually using these tools and
we didn't want to interrupt that we
didn't want to change that world for
them but we wanted to give them as a yet
just a different option camille and
switch for them to say i want to try a
different cluster or work with a
different cluster some of the unique
things we ended up coming up with you
know we get to use all the sky like so a
lot of the performance actually is is
it's coming up to show pretty pretty
strong so this is what we started out
with wouldn't be jumped in here that we
there was already an AWS implementation
michael and his team did a great job at
putting that together to kind of show
the two sides i originally started as
seeing the bottom portion of the diagram
there that was the original everything
was on-premise everything was set up to
the network's
storage arrays accepted and whatnot
that's where all the data actually lives
it was expanded into basically an almost
exact copy into AWS and tied together
with a VPN where possible they you know
dropped in store like bucket storage for
us three and other types of technologies
there so before I get into like how we
what we did for our side of it I kind of
went maybe take a small step back and
talk about what is multi cloud and and
and why their approach like where we
agree with their approach and we
consistently work on or we have a lot of
clients would end up approaching both
AWS and DCP made a little Azure here in
there anyway so what is multi cloud I
think you guys have heard this multiple
times over you know and I'm not going to
go too deep into that itself but I think
an interesting note to see here is that
a research that just came out 81% of
enterprises have a multi cloud strategy
a lot of the time they say that other
cloud is a private cloud but it's a it's
a we yeah it's a they generally will
take a private cloud internally and then
lo expand it out to one we're starting
to see that trend change and we're
starting to see more cloud adoption on
multiple cloud so it's not just one and
that's where you start building the
tools that we need in order to be able
to facilitate and interface into the
different two into the different clouds
there are some big benefits one avoiding
a vendor lock-in and in a moment we'll
describe that as also being a negative
two but avoiding
interlocking so if you need to move your
your applications around or your
computer around it's easy to do
it's nice when there's outages if you're
the one one company is still able to
continue to do their work when something
fat-fingers s3 and it goes down you know
it's uh it's kind of nice
also with multi multi cloud you get to
take the best and breed tools for each
of the different vendors I think that's
an important piece to think about vendor
lock-in is okay if you're using it for
the right purpose so if if the tool and
you know for example here the we're
going to now enable the researchers to
start using things like genomics API
which they technically didn't really
have an easy access into now that we
start having that relationship with
Google that data is closer they can
start using using the API so that's the
best in breed type of a tool so there
are challenges to doing multi cloud and
I think this is kind of a cool little
Venn diagram I drew up here where like
if when you when you get into it if you
really only want to be completely
agnostic you end up with the lowest
common denominator
meaning that you're only doing compute
you're only doing network you know and
well that's about it actually so if you
want to use any of the cool fate
features and functionality that come as
a managed provider there's not available
so keep that in mind when you're
thinking about where your strategies are
with with doing multi cloud it also does
increase maintenance and governance so
you have to maintain multiple different
platforms and that means it's also
operationally now you have folks that
have to you know teams who have to
understand all the platforms I mean that
can be a challenge to a lot of companies
as well so how do we go about doing this
we in a you know as an industry we've
built the tools now to allow us to kind
of have a little bit of a homogeneous
infrastructure so we heavily use we're
very big fans of hashey core in general
as a company
pouchy core has a product called packer
what allows you to do is it allows you
to define what you want an image or
virtual machine to look like and it will
build that image for you and and
either push it into the cloud you want
to or build it within the cloud you want
to so with that we can have the same
base level of an AWS image we can have
the same one in GCP and the same one
on-premise largely just the same file
and you just run it with different
providers so that sets us up for cave to
create a base level at that point then
on top of that we we look at what other
what other binaries and applications
need to be on those machines one of
those in this case here a lot of the
slurm and the cluster a lot of the slurm
demons and those types of things
applications have to be on each of the
different machines so in that case we
have to you chef chef is a great a great
tool for configuration management a lot
is to great once and use in multiple
different environments we are we as a
company we expanded this into with Fred
Fred hush here but as a company we
embrace infrastructure as code it's
something that we we think that every
company needs to do and and we basically
automate everything that's kind of my
little tagline I talk about that way too
much so but it needs to be said so when
we came in for Google and this is very
specific to Google we wrote I'm sure all
you guys have you done stuff on Google
you immediately know that it's not the
easiest thing in the world to start with
you get a whole pile of Docs you say now
what what we did is we wrote a
foundation layer we use terraform so
what this does it allows us to spell out
what a base applicant are say a base
Network and project structure looks like
within a Google project so we can run
this with a we set up real simply and it
defines that so we can move projects
around should we need to in a folder
structure it also sets up identity
management into a layered structure so
we can do organization folders and
projects in in a hierarchy so that that
foundation gets run once sets it up then
we have what we call our services layer
and this is where we actually provision
manage services you know such things as
you know cloud sequel or or other
dependent applications that are other
the dependent managed services that I
need to
within the the project and then at the
last layer we actually have an active we
call it the cap layer and this is where
you're actively installing or updating
or changing deploying rapidly changing
services within your infrastructure
I don't think ahead on the next one
nope I'll say it anyway so one little
tip that we like to try and say at all
of our talks is when you're using
infrastructure as code if there's a
possibility to run it in the continuous
integration environment definitely do
that
terraform is another hashey core product
what it does it allows you to be
declarative about what you want your
infrastructure to look like so you can
say I want you know this is the type of
machine I want I want 200 of them and
it's just a variable you change that and
you run it and allows you to declare
your leaf or give a declarative format
for what your infrastructure is when you
run that into a with a CI it means that
you no longer have an individual has to
run it off a laptop or even on a jump
box you now can have the same run happen
every single time it's all the benefits
you get from running a CI CD kind of
little side effect of that as well
terraform when it when it builds your
infrastructure it creates a state file
so it knows what your infrastructure
looks like without having to go
necessarily back to the cloud so it can
kind of manage itself now along with
that the benefits are if you want to
heavily govern or you want to govern
your infrastructure so you're not
running you know high cost or you want
to make sure that individuals only have
certain access you generally don't want
to give access to the console or it's a
G cloud which is the the command line
tool so use terraform to make all your
changes it forces you to run through a
pattern when you're using a CI render
pattern that you actually get to do all
of your own code reviews on your
infrastructure going out so you know
exactly what your infrastructure is at
any given time and you can say you know
you know a change doesn't go through or
or whatnot so I talked about our base
images so in in our case here our base
images we everything is using a bun -
because use some sentro sometimes no
it's mostly it's a bun - bun to cook yes
so the general idea here is that you you
created
image in that image is being pushed up I
can't really talk through that so here's
what the provisioning kind of looked
like for us we kind of started out with
the base OS image and and we used just
the really enough and auditors really
vanilla on top of that depending on the
different machines themselves a lot of
them needed to have the the tools that
the research was using so for example
the SDK for for our Sam tool tensorflow
etc by the way tensorflow is something
that we are currently looking into to
saying can we have that added on as
being early sat on GPUs into these
clusters we haven't done that yet but
it's on the roadmap all right and then
at the very top you know if you have but
all this learned dependencies and
they're working with it another thing
that was a kind of a challenge that we
had to fit is all the data we set her to
multiplies but all the data actually was
back at HQ so researchers throw all
their data other everything comes in
this is on net storage and we use the
NFS to transfer it out to the cloud for
the actual computer itself so there are
some challenges in that solution as well
just due to the latency that happens
with moving very large amounts of data
all right actually I already covered
this so I'm going to skip that slide all
right so largely the the solution itself
from a technology perspective wasn't
super super difficult but what I did is
I created a homogeneous infrastructure
between all the different providers that
they were working with with on-prem with
VMware AWS and GCP and so with that that
allows operations you know I'd mentioned
previously that operations when you're
doing multiple different clouds it can
be a nightmare if you don't have some
level of common between all of them so
this gives us that ability so here's the
kind of the final depth I've kind of
grayed out the AWS one because it's less
important but yeah we actually run this
cluster over a couple different zones
which is nice so we do have some high
availability built into the the
clustering of the application arm say of
the the slurm cluster and along that we
have a lot of attached storage that ends
up working with that
all the different systems run over VPN
back into the general networks so that
you have accessibility to to the data
back back in HQ so ongoing challenges
and we kind of alluded to the fact that
slurm itself as a as a product doesn't
have dynamic clustering or it does not
have dynamic scale you can't just throw
a new machine into the cluster and have
it Auto recognize Google did do a
product like I said that that does kind
of help with that but it's not it's not
public yet or the press loops this but
the code isn't so another challenges you
know I did any management is another one
to that we are still you know making
sure we try to stay on top of I did any
management like I am in general so what
boxes have access to what data what
researchers have access to what right
now we have a very very generic policy
that is maybe a little too permissive
but it's a it's a challenge because you
have to match that up with AWS and also
what you're doing with your on-prem so
alright so at the very end so whatever
you do by going through all of this one
we took the existing solution that Mike
Michael and his team put together I
would say we strengthened it in certain
ways we brought in a lot of dev nines
best practices on how we put together
infrastructure as code how we run it and
so we kind of strengthened that so we
did help out the AWS and also the
on-premise version of the of the cluster
but by virtually we also added the
capabilities for Google we were able to
now provide a 50/50 split for Google and
AWS traffic for cloud which now means
that they can scale even larger the
amount of data if you sound like 1.2
petabytes a day that's a lot of data so
having that they now have the capacity
or the capability of growing that even
larger as they need and matching the
same amount of compute that they need or
the demand they have they don't have a
lot of resource contention now so
alright so in the future we are looking
at adding in the capabilities of using
genomics API along with
any of the other machine learning the
hosted tensorflow
right now a lot of the researchers are
using tensor flow but it's the self
managed and it's non non GPU based often
TP use so it's it's still very it's very
early days for that but it's a lot of
the data they're doing it does we
doesn't necessarily choir but it's a
something where they want to start be
able to use it so we're we're expanding
the solution to be able to add those
types of capabilities to it also right
now all the data as we mentioned is
on-premise but also all the computers
generally in the u.s. Fred hutch has
multiple centers around the world and so
be able to actually use this same
solution because we've now created this
infrastructure is code we can now create
that same infrastructure in multiple
different regions around the world and
still have the same infrastructure for
them and then the last thing is it's
it's a it's a hope but we like to
actually bill to add in some pre-emptive
machines as well to this to kind of help
lower the cost a lot of that's going to
come with the synchronization and the
automation that we're doing for
identifying when you want to build new
cluster or add more to a cluster and
redeploy it so we're working on some of
those pieces but that will be kind of a
fun next up for us
you
[Music]